[Música]
una visita entre socios una visita entre
amigos el presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva está de visita en
China su principal socio comercial la
visita de rula da Silva es bastante
significativa es el regreso de Brasil a
la escena internacional como un actor de
peso de Liderazgo del sur global y que
entre tantos temas en su agenda tiene
fortalecer el brix y también acercar a
China al mercosur veamos el informe que
preparó la redacción de France 24
en un reinicio de las relaciones entre
Brasil y China después de cuatro años de
relativo aislamiento internacional con
el expresidente Jair bolsonaro el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
tiene un objetivo claro fortalecer el
vínculo ya profundo entre Brasilia y
Beijing China es el principal socio
comercial de Brasil y un importante
mercado para la soja el mineral de
hierro y el petróleo Brasil es también
el mayor receptor de inversión china en
América Latina durante su visita estado
el presidente Lula también tiene un
segundo objetivo reactivar la alianza
brix una agrupación de las principales
economías de Mercado emergentes del
mundo compuesta por Brasil Rusia India
China y Sudáfrica una idea que Beijing
parece ver con buenos ojos
china está dispuesta a trabajar con
Brasil para utilizar Esta visita como
una oportunidad para promover una
cooperación mutuamente beneficiosa y
amistosa entre los países en desarrollo
y para abordar juntos los desafíos
globales
se espera también que Lula asista a la
toma de posesión de la expresidenta
Dilma hussef como directora del banco de
desarrollo brix el cual Busca la
creación de una moneda común que permita
a los socios comerciales evitar el uso
del dólar a finales de marzo China y
Brasil anunciaron un acuerdo para
comerciar entre sí sus monedas
nacionales Lula tenía previsto viajar a
Beijing en ese momento pero lo pospuso
debido a una enfermedad
sin embargo envió parte de su delegación
compuesta por representantes del
gobierno y empresas privadas Allí se
concluyeron más de 20 acuerdos
comerciales en varios sectores
también sobre la mesa que Brasil se una
a la iniciativa de la nueva ruta de la
seda un gigantesco proyecto de inversión
china que a Beijing le gustaría extender
aún más en América del Sur
el peso que recae sobre Brasil a nivel
internacional como un país líder de
América Latina es grande la expectativa
también lo es por la coyuntura actual
que deja América Latina que está en en
una posición digamos poco atractiva y
poco visible en el escenario
internacional por su condición económica
y política Brasil entonces puede
despertar el interés a nivel
internacional y atraer ese interés hacia
la zona de América Latina Brasil Siempre
será un país atractivo a nivel político
y económico para el relacionamiento de
nuestra región así lo dicen algunos
analistas por eso hoy en el debate de
France 24 pues analizamos la gira del
presidente Luis y nació Lula da Silva
por China para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a Cayo mañanelli él es
consultor político y director de la
asociación brasileña de consultores
políticos se encuentran la ciudad de
Brasilia en el Distrito Federal y desde
foz de iguazú en el Estado de Paraná se
conecta Fabio bor Él es director del
Instituto latinoamericano de economía
sociedad y política de la universidad
Federal de integración latinoamericana
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte del debate y pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
también en Facebook y también nos
encuentran en instagram como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es en numeral el
debate f24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y
también en TuneIn
muy bien entonces lo doy la bienvenida a
Cayo en la ciudad de Brasilia en la
capital brasileña y comenzó por
preguntarle eso que se ha comenzado a
decir en la prensa internacional de
Brasil está de vuelta al escenario
internacional impresiones entonces de
Esta visita del presidente Lula da Silva
a China
Hola Santiago Sí primeramente buena
Muchas gracias por tenerme en cuenta es
un gusto estar acá con ustedes
sí la perspectiva de la del regreso de
Brasil
en la perspectiva desde la las
elecciones
no no Luna empezó el gobierno de hecho
con una agenda bastante intensa de
visitaciones Internacionales incluso eh
su primero movimiento internacional
tiene que ver justamente con el mercosur
y Y eso es básicamente algo como cumplir
una promesa de campaña pero
es muy importante
de de apertura así como de entrada que
es dejar muy claro que
para la para la población brasileña el
senado Internacional no pesa tanto en
relación a el apoyo de sus mandatarios
Así que claro nula está haciendo todo
ese esfuerzo en busca de que esto sea
la palanca para que ayuden la economía
brasileña a volver a índices de
crecimiento razonables o por lo menos
adecuados al tamaño del país
y ahora le doy la palabra a Fabio
nuestro siguiente invitado también le
doy la bienvenida al programa Gracias
por estar con nosotros él se conecta
desde foz de iguazú en el Estado de
Paraná Fabio también está usted de
acuerdo con esta frase de Brasil ha
regresado Pisando fuerte al escenario
internacional y cuáles son sus
impresiones de Esta visita del
presidente brasileño a China
Hola Santiago Hola un gusto hablar con
ustedes Sí estoy de acuerdo en los
últimos cuatro años la política externa
de Brasil Fue bastante problemática
voluntario de Brasil del escenario
internacional y claramente Lola Regresa
con una política que ya era su marca en
el primer mandato la idea de la
diversificación de los socios políticos
de Los Socios comerciales Brasil tiene
un peso grande en Latinoamérica Entonces
es un país que cuando no está
involucrado en los procesos difícilmente
los procesos de integración camino y
nuestra región y por otro lado es un
momento diferente de la historia
entonces no es tan fácil Brasil liderar
un proceso Como hizo en los años 2002
2010 que era un momento de Boom de las
como
el mercado estaba mucho más aquecido el
problema de la pandemia no había la
guerra en Ucrania entonces las líneas
generales de la política brasileña de
acercamiento Sudamérica acercamiento a
los brics me parece que es una
continuidad de los dos primeros periodos
de Luna pero en un contexto mucho más de
diverso entonces por ahí se cree
expectativas pero también te quería un
pensamiento un poco equilibrado de qué
va a lograr realmente con Esta visita la
perspectiva inicial de nuestros dos
invitados pasó a darle la palabra a cayó
él menciona la importancia de la
política
doméstica y la atención que está
teniendo Esta visita en China a nivel
local justamente para allá Quiero
enrutar la pregunta para hablar de
economía porque si algo lleva en la
agenda del presidente Lula da Silva es
esa intención de firmar cerca de 20
acuerdos comerciales con china ya es su
principal socio comercial como vayamos
en el reportaje
qué tanta expectativa hay en el entorno
económico dentro del empresariado
brasileño y dentro de los mismos
brasileños sobre lo que pueda significar
estos acuerdos con China
Santiago déjame
Perdóname Fabio Por no tener saludado de
hecho es un gusto poder estar acá con
profesor de la la buenísima universidad
iniciativa de hecho de integración
latinoamericana uno de los mejores
aparatos que se quedaron en relación
incluso a cumplir algo que el mercosur
siempre se reclamó que no cumplió que es
un proyecto de integración
latinoamericana un proyecto de
integración de los países es un gusto
poder estar con el profesor Fabio acá y
ojalá pueda yo visitarlo que ahora en
poco tiempo voy a estar en tránsito
pasado en mayo le voy a buscar ahí para
tomar un café en la universidad Bueno
pues ahí queda France 24 y América
Latina de testigo de ese compromiso Cayo
sí Seguro seguro por ahí voy a pasar
seguramente voy a pasar ahí en mayo
Bueno lo que lo que te comento sobre el
tema primero así ahí leemos de hecho la
opinión pública nacional
los medios pueden presionar en relación
a lo que pasa internacionalmente con
Brasil pero la gente está preocupada con
su día a día con la falta de dinero con
la carne que nos logra comprar el
brasileño se la acostumbró mal Quizás a
comer carne de vacuno todos los días y
en los últimos cuatro años el brasileño
tuvo de Buscar puestos para poder
complementar su dieta diaria lo que hizo
con que el país volviera a la línea de
la miseria Entonces el principal
proyecto de Lula para su pueblo para su
aprobación en el Brasil no tiene que ver
con china Estados Unidos con Unión
Europea no tiene que ver con el senado
Internacional tiene que ver con lo que
va a lograr hacer con la economía
brasileña bueno el paso es que
claro no está no está mal vista la
visita de Lula por parte del empresario
brasileño y vamos por declaraciones por
ejemplo de Carlos faro que un político
de Centro derecha que está dentro del
gobierno como ministro de agricultura y
que es uno de los grandes lodistas o por
lo menos representantes del agronegocio
muy interesado y muy interesado de hecho
en cambiar la moneda de de de de aceptar
por lo menos la participación de Brasil
en la nueva fruta de la cera es de este
proyecto
gigantesco que china está lindo como
para para usar préstamos y desarrollar
los países pero Brasil no necesita de
eso en verdad porque china ya invierte
mucha plata en Brasil y China ya es el
principal
parcial económico de Brasil Para que
veas china compra veinte millones de
dólares compró 20 millones de dólares
solo en este primero trimestre y compró
diez millones de dólares de Brasil y
Estados Unidos compró diez millones de
dólares quiere decir Brasil exporta el
doble
que a Estados Unidos Estados Unidos
tomado con en Unión Europea sumamente
tres billones de dólares en el trimestre
en cuanto china es son 20 billones de
dólares esto quiere decir hay una
balanza comercial bastante equilibrada
entre los países supuestamente se llaman
de occidentales y el país que
supuestamente seríamos de Oriental que
son cortes muy muy sencillos para cerrar
esta idea tenemos en cuenta que las
reservas brasileñas están 80% en dólares
y tres por ciento la moneda china los
objetivos de Esta visita china quiere
empezar a negociar con Brasil a partir
de su moneda así se cambió el eje de
Inglaterra Estados Unidos y así se va a
cambiar el eje de Estados Unidos a China
en la economía mundial entonces china el
objetivo de China esencial es lograr
empezar a
usar su propia moneda para nosotros
acciones con Brasil
comercializar entre estos dos países en
sus respectivas monedas ya sea joano ya
sea real Brasileño le doy la palabra a
Fabio sobre este tema económico que como
buena parte de las economías a nivel
internacional la brasileña también Está
tratando de terminar de reponerse
después de lo que fue el impacto de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 y haciendo frente
también a problemas como la inflación
Aunque hay que decir que la economía
brasileña está saliendo más o menos bien
librada si la comparamos con otros
países de la región de América Latina su
perspectiva Fabio sobre lo que significa
a nivel económico para los brasileños
Esta visita
yo creo que hay que hacer el análisis en
diferentes dimensiones hay una dimensión
del sistema internacional yo creo que
está muy claro que hay una transición
hegemónica de Estados Unidos para china
aunque sea más comercial o que militar y
política en este momento pero es muy
famoso un mapa reciente de economist que
demuestra que a 20 años detrás de
Estados Unidos tenía el mundo como su
principal socio comercial y ahora chino
pasó claramente como en Sudamérica
prácticamente todos los países tiene
China como el principal socio comercial
entonces esos cambios pueden ser
utilizados del punto de vista de los
latinoamericanos y del brazo como
mecanismo de negociación me parece
interesante los países Brasil y los
países en conjunto aprovechar esa
coyuntura para intentar sacar montaje de
hacer relaciones con China de un lado
Estados Unidos de otro lado Unión
Europea del otro lado yo creo que ese
escenario Abre esta posibilidad de
negociar en diferentes tableros pero es
muy claro que latinoamérica es uno de
los continentes que más sufrieron con la
pandemia y más sufrieron como este
momento de la economía mundial por temas
estructurales de dependencia de
vulnerabilidad falta de tecnología falta
de infraestructura entonces china Parece
ser un camino Muy interesante para
Brasil Brasil necesita de
infraestructura necesita de crédito
necesita de inversiones En esas áreas
que pueden traer beneficios internos y
de popularidad interna porque eso puede
hacer diferencia y al mismo tiempo es
una continuidad de sus líneas de
política externa de 20 años detrás que
esta política de defensa del
multilateralismo y de crítica las
instituciones existentes por ejemplo fmi
Fabio continuó con usted porque usted
mencionaba que el escenario
internacional es muy distinto la
coyuntura internacional es muy diferente
y si bien ya Brasil y China tienen una
relación sólida bien establecida ustedes
ya lo han puesto con ejemplos muy claros
lo han dejado así muy claro en esta
nueva fase digámoslo así si se le puede
llamar así de relaciones entre Brasilia
y Beijing en qué estarán marcado porque
como usted lo decía
en los primeros gobiernos de Lula estaba
más enmarcado en la necesidad de de
commodities de un intercambio una
necesidad de Brasil de recibir dinero
para mejorar infraestructuras Brasil le
vendía entonces diferentes minerales
petróleo Bueno este tipo de la lista es
larga pero en el escenario actual
En qué se benefician los dos países qué
comercializan ahora en el nuevo
escenario
es el gran desafío de Brasil cómo
diversificar las exportaciones para
China cómo garantizar una transferencia
de tecnología de los chinos para Brasil
yo creo que los temas centrales eran
jueces del punto de vista del brazo del
punto de vista de China yo creo que
china está sufriendo largamente en el
escenario internacional un conflicto con
Estados Unidos de un conflicto creciente
Entonces yo creo que para china es
interesante fortalecer los brinques se
acercara y de Brasil o de India de
Sudáfrica intentar tener buenas
relaciones con con Rusia también no es
fácil en ese escenario geopolítico de
conflictos en Ucrania pero ahí está
algunos de los desafíos que yo veo
claramente entonces Brasil por un lado
tiene que tener buenas relaciones con
china pero también no quiere quedar mal
con Estados Unidos entonces inserta
medida Brasil tiene algunas posturas por
por ejemplo hoy El ministro de la
economía de Brasil crítico
el trabajo es grave en China es difícil
imaginar
mandatarios brasileños haciendo hizo en
China diplomáticamente es un riesgo pero
estamos preocupados también con la
competitividad interna de Brasil no es
fácil competir con china entonces china
Yo creo que es un un desafío para todas
las partes del mundo y para Brasil no es
diferente entonces hay que garantizar
acuerdos que
tragan algún tipo de equilibrio
económico con transferencia de
tecnología y con la posibilidad de
diversificación de las exportaciones de
Brasil y algo tiene de ventaja Brasil
tal vez ustedes me corrigen si no es así
lo que uno ve desde otros países de
América Latina es que Brasil estableció
desde hace muchos años una dinámica
comercial y diplomática a todo nivel sin
importar los actores simplemente para
estrechar lazos y sacar beneficios
comerciales desde ambos lados y por
Brasil no se le critica tanto que hable
con Rusia que hable con china no vemos a
Estados Unidos viendo con malos ojos
Esta visita de Lula da Silva a China
cosa muy diferente sería si otro país
latinoamericano un México un Colombia un
chile un Perú estuviera en este tipo de
situación buscando nuevos mercados o
buscando nuevas posibilidades económicas
y diplomáticas tal vez el escenario
sería muy diferente otros dos puntos que
quiero analizar con ustedes importantes
del escenario internacional 1 los brics
Cayo que es tal vez uno de los puntos
destacados de esta agenda la necesidad
de relanzar los bricks pero ahí entran
países que son muy particulares en el
escenario político entendamos Que brix
es más económico pero pero allí está
Rusia está India gran Aliado de Rusia en
este momento comprándole petróleo
también está Sudáfrica que es uno de los
países que ha tomado una postura
internacional frente a la guerra en
Ucrania a favor de Rusia puede correr el
riesgo brix de convertirse en una
formación política a nivel internacional
tomar una postura a favor de Rusia
bueno Santiago no es difícil de disociar
economía de de política
pero claro los intereses económicos
están por encima entonces para contar un
poco lo que decía sobre el multinacional
multilateralismo brasileño y
los Mira la la visita de Brasil no
está feliz con la visita brasileña a
China pero no puede evitarlo y tampoco
puede sancionarlo porque hoy Brasil
también es un parcero muy importante en
Estados Unidos Estados Unidos defiende
mucho de Brasil en verdad que en el
escenario competitivo internacional como
decía Fabio con decir el profesor Fabio
es muy correcto pensar que china no es
solo un consumidor pero que también como
como país en desarrollo es también un
competidor de Brasil
hay dos objetivos como te dice claros
del lado chino es empezar a establecer
su moneda como la referencia de tránsito
de de comercio internacional de lado
brasileño es restablecer
ejes importantes para el desarrollo del
país con la ayuda china no es tan
sencillo que en China va a transmitir
tecnología Brasil a pesar de que eso es
siempre lo que Brasil pide Esto está
súper normal se perdió eso a Europa se
va a pedir a China del principal tema es
que china no está tan interesada en el
petróleo brasileño entonces por eso
puede ser que china ayude a Brasil a
desarrollar lo que fue ensayado con el
campus de libras Y ahí tiene todo un
contexto del petróleo pero muy
posiblemente lo que Brasil quiere es que
china venga nuevamente a desarrollar lo
que se quedó parado de desarrollo de
exploración de petróleo china lo que
quiere es poder cruzar los océanos y
acortar la distancia para llevar los dos
principales productos que compran de la
América del Sur en especial entre Brasil
Perú Qué es soja Brasil Perú en el caso
de Paraguay no directamente pero del
mercosur en general es soja no
y medio de viejo estos son los dos
productos principales que china necesita
entonces lo que china quiere es que
Brasil sea lo que fue para Estados
Unidos en su momento el proveedor de
insumos para que china pueda
desarrollarse tecnológicamente con más
fuerza está trayendo incluso a Brasil la
fábrica de eso es uno de las cosas que
ya se está celebrando ya está
prácticamente
de autos tecnológicos híbridos está
Avenida Brasil y
icónicamente va a ocupar el lugar donde
la forma ocupaba exactamente la planta
de fábrica que
en Brasil va a ser ocupada por la de y
así que solo para acotar esa situación
Entonces
los brics pueden venir a convertirse en
una en una maniobra política pero al
mismo tiempo es muy difícil
está mezclado pero al mismo tiempo que
prevalece es el comercial entonces hay
sin intereses comercial de usar el brick
para financiar obras en otros países
pero Estados Unidos
de una manera clara como un un una
potencia política en contra la Unión
Europea y en contra Estados Unidos va a
mantenerse obviamente interviniendo en
términos políticos Pero claro con la
prioridad económica es muy para terminar
la Guerra de Ucrania y Rusia es una
cuestión de tiempo para acabar no no se
está escalando la violencia en relación
se está quedando difícil mantener esta
guerra
rentable a Europa debemos acabar con eso
pronto Sí pues es muy incidente que esta
Automotriz china llegue a ocupar las
instalaciones donde en su momento
funcionó en Automotriz estadounidense
Eso habla mucho de la expansión
internacional china Fabio para cerrar
este tema de los bricks le doy la
palabra sobre ese fortalecimiento que
necesita entonces este bloque para para
volver a despegar a nivel internacional
ya que Brasil está tan decidido de
volverlo a poner en el escenario
internacional y pues obviamente los
países que Lo componen También tienen el
interés de volverlo a catapultar a nivel
internacional
Yo creo que es más fácil y quizás tenga
más interés en avanzar en términos
económicos por eso la consolidación la
formación de los bancos de desarrollo de
los brinques desde 2014 Incluso en el
periodo que idioma Josefa era la
presidenta de Brasil Entonces es muy
significativo que hoy idioma José sea la
presidenta del nuevo banco de desarrollo
de los brinques demuestra que Brasil
valora mucho esta institución que sería
una institución complementaria Banco
Mundial a fondo monetario internacional
pero para el mundo del Sur con los
problemas ambientales con los problemas
de energías limpias con créditos en
condicionalidades como en ONU es muy
común a estas condicionalidades que en
muchos momentos como ven habló hoy Lula
estranguló las economías sudamericanas
como ajustes estructurales muy profundos
Entonces en este sentido el banco y con
los intereses de China de
ocupar ese espacio Incluso en las
transacciones de monedas chinesas yo
creo que está yendo bien Hasta cierto
punto el banco porque las agencias de
clasificación de riesgo ponen el banco
como altas calificaciones O sea no es un
banco puramente político tiene toda una
realidad económica y una lógica de banco
también no
es un banco que además la gran mayoría
de los préstamos los ha dado justamente
a Brasil para proyectos de
infraestructura Fabio continuó con usted
porque también me parece importante que
analicemos otro grupo al que pertenece
Brasil que es de suma importancia
regional y es el mercosur en donde
también hay unas discrepancias internas
entonces en torno a como aproximarse a
China Paraguay no tiene relaciones con
china pero Uruguay está deseoso de
firmar un acuerdo comercial de libre
comercio con china Brasil ahora pues da
este impulso también aquí en en ese
ánimo también de relanzarle el mercosur
que está bastante en un estado de pausa
digámoslo así
qué rumbo puede analizar usted para el
mercosur
es un otro gran desafío no hace tiempo
mercosur especialmente en los últimos
cuatro años no avanzó inclusive yo creo
que jetro en algunos sentidos pero ahora
hay una convergencia ideológica entre
Lola Fernández Yo creo que el presidente
de Paraguay va a tener buenas relaciones
con Brasil también y claro china es
seductora para todos no pero en realidad
yo hablé con algunos intelectuales
uruguayos en una investigación reciente
tampoco hacer un acuerdo bilateral entre
Uruguay y China va a solucionar los
problemas de Uruguay yo creo que Uruguay
el negocio No solo con china
trae muchos problemas para mercosur pero
también para Uruguay muchas cosas Va a
continuar exportando materias primas Va
a continuar importando productos
tecnológicos y con desequilibrios
comerciales y ahí yo creo que Brasil
puede ser un intermediario importante
para no incluir
mercosur por los intereses chinos Y por
esa seducción que algunos países tengo
pero mismo tiempo traer China para
negociar con el bloque yo creo que esta
es la tarea el bloque y los bloques
sudamericanos latinoamericanos pensar en
estrategias colectivas para sacar
provecho de de estas relaciones con país
tan Dinámico como china normalmente
pensamos china sabe lo que quiere de
nosotros y nosotros qué queremos de
China recordemos un ordenamos un poquito
mejor nuestra relaciones
tanto
mercosur una Sur aquí pueden traer ahí
una coordinación esencial para sacarnos
mejores condiciones para negociar con
china sí y dejar de ver la relación
desde América Latina simplemente como un
país que viene a hacer grandes
inversiones En infraestructura a hacer
lo que no han hecho los gobiernos en los
últimos años a tratar de salvar lo que
no se ha podido hacer en los últimos en
los últimos años y ver que es un socio
que puede llegar mucho más allá que
simplemente venir a hacer puertos
aeropuertos carreteras y metros cayó le
doy la palabra para que hablemos del
tema de mercosur Quiero conocer su
opinión sobre este tema
Santiago
yo uno de los países que trabajo es
Paraguay De hecho yo trabajo entre
Brasil y Paraguay por eso que voy a
visitar a Fabio pronto porque voy a
estar justamente en tránsito entre los
dos países y a mí me gusta usar
justamente las carreteras que quizás los
chinos empieza a construir pero todavía
son empresas razonablemente nacionales
Cuál es el gran tema a ver sobre mercos
primero volviendo al tema del banco del
banco nuevo banco de desarrollo uno de
los países que tiene préstamo con el
nuevo banco de desarrollo se llama
Uruguay Uruguay tiene ya tiene préstamo
este banco no es porque es el banco de
los que solo presta plata a los brics
esto quiere decir que este banco está
siendo fomentado por los países con que
compone el pero este banco ya presta y
como dijiste muy bien Santiago funciona
como un banco y ya presta plata a otros
países que hacen parte de otros bloques
y que estén que estén en otros en otros
espacios entonces Uruguay que tiene un
presidente
a ver sabemos que Uruguay nunca está a
la derecha a la izquierda no pero eh es
claro como tenemos claro que el máximo
de derecha que puede llegar a Uruguay es
representado por su presidente actual
Paraguay que tiene un presidente de
derecha es en país que está forzando ya
hace un año por ahí para más Quizás una
un acuerdo con china pero Cuáles son las
condicionantes y Hablaste muy bien de
Paraguay una de las posiciones
son cuatro países Paraguay Uruguay
Argentina y Brasil una de las
condiciones de esas que Paraguay deje de
reconocer a tayuba y esto está muy claro
en la agenda política y las promesas de
él dejó muy claro que quiere poner
resuelto en su mandato ahora los
problemas territoriales de China
Entonces está muy claro que Paraguay es
un entrave para que Uruguay pueda
mejorar las condiciones
de comercio con china uno de los
objetivos de china en el Continente como
disminuir una instancia de logística
parar de trapear por el Atlántico y
empezar a tragar las mercancías por el
Pacífico para eso sería necesario
terminar de construir algunos o por lo
menos uno de los corredores bioceánicos
ya existe uno y pasa por el Perú Solo
que el Perú está muy al norte y es un
corredor que no se usa mucho el otro
corredor que ya está listo el proyecto y
que ya empieza a terminar es el corredor
que pasa justamente por Paraguay
Entonces ese corredor tiene función
estratégica para China y en cuanto
Paraguay no acepta sigue aceptando
situaciones diplomáticas con Taiwán Sí
exactamente lo que lo que china no va a
querer es poder poner oficialmente plata
para terminar este corredor porque sería
un problema Esto sí sería un problema
para los cineses puede ser que Brasil
esté ahí para mediar justamente este
conflicto donde Paraguay no deje de
reconocer tu ayuda y al mismo tiempo
llegue la plata china pero por
intermedio de Brasil y esto ya pasa con
la soja Santiago claro las hojas
paraguayas se ven de Brasil y de Brasil
se va a China claro entonces ahí hay
varias varias cositas que son varios
detalles muy interesantes muy muy
integrados digamos muy lleno de sazón
sobre
grabaciones muy paradoxales Como por
ejemplo de un presidente de derecho que
busca un gobierno
voy entrando ya al bloque final de el
programa y quiero que hablemos sobre lo
que significa liderazgo de Lula da Silva
no solamente en Brasil sino también en
América Latina Tal parece que está
logrando en muy corto tiempo de haber
empezado su presidencia a tomar un
liderazgo regional este tipo de visitas
que ha hecho las personas con las que se
han reunido Lula da Silva del escenario
internacional no lo ha logrado Gabriel
borich no lo ha logrado el presidente
Gustavo Petro en Colombia y pues tampoco
ni siquiera Andrés Manuel López Obrador
en México Aquí hay una oportunidad para
para Brasil ser el gran líder
latinoamericano ser también además ese
gran líder del sur global como lo ve
usted hago la ronda la inversa Cayo
comienzo con usted y muy puntual por
favor porque tengo poco tiempo
no puede ser rápido conciso con eso como
dicen los paraguayos
básicamente
Lula primero ya era una una ya había un
volumen de visitaciones Internacionales
de prestigio internacional Así que Lula
dejó la prisión Entonces esto Esto fue
bastante intenso
como candidato ya era mirado como un
nuevo presidente y por la comunidad
internacional Entonces esto es una cosa
que está claro pero la la
dos motivos enseñan
colaboro para que para que Lula sea este
liderazgo internacional Primero su gran
característica de ser un gran mediador
siempre fue desde el movimiento sindical
de los setenta hasta hoy es un gran tipo
un gran mediador un gran negociador
segundo la importancia económica de
Brasil para el mundo y para el bloque
regional Brasil es el principal
parcero comercial e inmediato de
básicamente todos los países del América
del Sur entonces teniendo esto en cuenta
es claro que el presidente del Brasil
tiene un potencial de hacer un gran
líder internacional por lo menos lo que
dice respeto al bloque de sus vecinos
bolso perdió por su incompetencia Clara
y por la falta de Liderazgo obvia que
tenía el señor y en el caso de Lula ya
sabemos es un político experimentado y
tiene todo para volver a ascender en su
liderazgo internacionalmente también y
Fabio su opinión sobre este liderazgo y
le prolongo la la pregunta la izquierda
o esta Nueva Ola de izquierda
latinoamericana claramente no tenía un
líder como si lo tuvo en su primer
momento Hugo Chávez que movió y movilizó
a la izquierda latinoamericana y a los
líderes a los presidentes de izquierda
que habían los otros países puede ser
Lula ese nuevo líder de la izquierda
latinoamericana y una izquierda no tan
radical como pudo haber sido la
izquierda de Chávez esta de pronto un
poco más matizada ya conociendo como es
el el estilo de gobierno y el manejo que
le da a él a estas intenciones políticas
de izquierda
yo creo que sí y comparto con la primera
característica de Lula es que es uno de
los políticos más de experiencia entre
todos esos que fueron mencionados hay
que decir que Lula está lindo para el
tercer mandato presidenciado en los dos
primeros ya tenía ese papel de Liderazgo
yo sumaría un otro punto importante no
así como para Brasil es importante
Sudamérica y latinoamérica para
latinoamérica y Sudamérica es
interesante negociar al lado de Brasil
por el tamaño de Brasil entonces esa
ausencia de liderazgo de Brasil afectó
todos los procesos de integración y mi
opinión y ahora será un trabajo enorme
la reconstrucción por ejemplo hace una
semana tanto Lula cuando Fernández
regresaron a la 1 azul Pero hay un
camino muy grande por adelante para
traer los otros países y una
multidimensional hay dos de Consejos
específicos por ejemplo con ha hecho
mucha falta en el momento de la pandemia
había un consejo de salud sudamericano
Entonces yo creo que ahí Lula va a
transitar más para la moderación claro
nunca fue de extrema izquierda Entonces
en este contexto que necesita moderación
en países tan fragmentados tan
polarizados yo creo que Lula tal vez
logre más fuera de Brasil que dentro de
Brasil esta armonía puede suceder pues
ya veremos qué más deja Esta visita del
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva Y qué más deja esa diplomacia
tan activa que tienes el mandatario
brasileño a nivel internacional ya
veremos en donde En qué otros escenarios
puede llegar a desenvolverse acá yo ya
Fabio les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros y haber hecho el
análisis para la audiencia de France 24
interesante ver cómo es ese giro en la
diplomacia brasileña con este cambio de
gobierno y a ustedes les agradezco por
la sintonía en nombre del equipo técnico
del debate de France 24 Les agradecemos
haber estado con nosotros la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y de Andrés doncell la producción
de invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
ustedes pueden seguir dejando todos los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]